there have been a lot of crazy eaders
throughout history many of which we've
looked at on this very channel but few
have been as depraved as the man who
absolutely brutalized Uganda throughout
the 1970s with his penchant for torture
severed heads by his own admission
cannibalism he thoroughly deserved the
description given to him by the man he
replaced as Ugandan president milton of
Beaute the greatest brute that an
african mother has brought to life in
this week's barn graphics we enter the
very bizarre world of real men
[Music]
Idi Amin Dada was born between 1925 and
1928 in kabocha Uganda his was the Kokua
tribe of which his mother was the witch
doctor he had very little formal
education but was versed in the
teachings of the Quran from a very early
age
in fact he developed a reputation as the
boy who could recite the Quran in his
early teens he won an award for this
ability young Adeeb spent his days in
the fields tending goats in his
mid-teens he got his first job as a hat
and coat person at the Imperial Hotel in
Lagasse it was there that he came to the
notice of a British Army officer it he
had grown into a tall strapping young
man he spoke the kiswahili language and
he had little education meaning he would
readily follow orders these were all
seen as desirable traits and the officer
pulled some strings to allow him to
enter the British colonial Army in 1946
it he began his military career as the
laundry worker in the Maha Maha barracks
in jigna after a year of this he
advanced to the 21st Kings African
Rifles Ely shortly thereafter his unit
was relocated to Somalia it he proved to
be a keen eager soldier his courage
boldness and cruelty were traits that
marked him as a standout private after
hunting down shifter animal raiders in
Somalia he was sent to Fort Hall where
he began training for the Scottish
military bands by the age of 20 Mitty
had grown into a young Dan off at six
foot four he weighed in at 240 pounds
and he was as strong as an ox he
excelled at boxing becoming the Ugandan
light heavyweight boxing champion as
well as an accomplished swimmer
[Music]
over the next two years idiom in Dada
established himself as an ideal soldier
one report described him as an
incredible person who is certainly not
mad
very shrewd very cunning and a born
leader
another report commented on his physical
and mental ability stating a splendid
and good rugby player but virtually bone
from the neck up and needs things
explained in words of one letter in 1952
Allman's Brigade was dispatched to Kenya
to fight against the Mau Mau rebellion
here he undertook foot patrols in the
jungle to root out the rebels his
initiative was rewarded by promotion for
us to corporal and then to sergeant by
the end of 1853 he returns the highest
rank that a black officer could attain
in the British colonial army and that
was the F and E this was the equivalent
of a Warrant Officer hunting down the
Mau Mau it wasn't the only thing that
I'm in did while in Kenya during those
two years he also fathered two children
a boy and a girl they were to be the
first of 35 children born by five wives
in 1954 armen's Brigade returns to their
base at ginger in Uganda when Queen
Elizabeth toured he was in the Scottish
army bands winning feat distinction of
being named best in parade in 1957 he
led a movement among the native soldiers
to get increased salaries the initiative
it failed and the army brass expressed
displeasure at this upstart move from
their star soldier disappointment came
when he twice failed the military
intelligence test as a result he was
transferred from the field to the Kings
African Rifles
and then in 1959 he passed the army
field exercise exam and was permitted
once more to serve in the field of
combat he was posted to the border
between Kenya and Uganda and here there
was a bitter rivalry between the Ugandan
caramel gong and the Kenyan Turkana
nomads here I was in the wake of a
crushing British defeat at the hands of
the Takada and performed so well that a
British officer described on min as
having restored the prestige of the
forces of law and order in the region of
cara maria in fact I'm in now promoted
to lieutenant was responsible for
negotiating a peace agreements with the
Takano leader Edward
Matea almonds means of achieving his
ends were unorthodox - to say the least
he threatens to cut off the penis of
every Turkana man who was found to be
rustling cattle and this wasn't just
bluffing
he followed through on this threat and
much more in fact the bloody manner in
which he crushed the rebellion brought a
level of ferociousness to the area that
was simply unprecedented
in 1962 Uganda won independence from
Great Britain suddenly the nation had
its own army whereas previously the
native brigades had been treated as
second-class soldiers by the British and
were doing the bidding of their colonial
overlords now they were free of those
shackles a large number of British
officers remained in Uganda to oversee
the emergence of the Ugandan army as
early as 1964 and began making moves to
gain military strength within the
Ugandan army his actions in putting down
the Takano rebellion brought him to the
attention of Uganda's first prime
minister milton de beauté and he
promoted the Hocking young fighter to
the position of deputy commander of the
army he was also putting commands of the
1st battalion of the Ugandan army in
1965 Armen led his battalion into the
Congo to support nationalists and resist
the foreign sport and government that
the mission was unsuccessful with the
agains and forces being repelled by the
Congolese mercenaries
later that year bummin became entangled
in a scandal involving the smuggling of
golden delivery President Frederick
mutation ii demanded his investigation
about a responded by making armed in
general and chief of staff and tasked
him with the strong handling of the
situation he then had five ministers
arrested and named himself as president
Amin was dispatched with an army force
to the place of President Matassa I mean
personally fired a 12 millimeter gun
that was mounted on its jeep to blow
holes in the president's palace walls
mutasa however had gone into hiding and
finished a flee to England in 1969 a
BOTY was pleased with the strongman
tactics of his right-hand man idiom in
in 1967 he gave him supreme command over
the army that senior it he enrolled at
university and took english classes he
would eventually receive a doctoral
degree from the University in 1969 idiom
ins leadership of the Ugandan army that
was challenged the Ugandan People's
Congress were attempting to bring about
reforms they had major concerns with the
tactics that the commander-in-chief was
using to the exert his control he had
established a pattern of brutalizing his
enemies fermenting massacres against
communities that appeared rebellious and
executing opposition leaders recognizing
these shifting winds and began to take
courses in socialism
[Music]
I'm ins brutality however it could not
be quelled when he was accused by
Brigadier General acquire of complicity
in an assassination attempt on president
boat I am in arranged for a choir to be
assassinated meanwhile tensions had
developed between a boat Hanuman idiot
focused on recruiting soldiers from his
own tribe in order to build up his
personal following then it was proven
that he had indeed been behind the
attempt on a boaters life at the same
time it was revealed that he had
misappropriated 40 million shillings
from the military operations fund in
1970 a boat a hat Amman fired from his
position as commander-in-chief of the
army and instructed his attorneys to
prepare a prosecution against him to
avoid arrest Amman fled to Kampala from
there he waited for his opportunity to
strike back at a boat a that opportunity
came On January the 25th 1971 on that
date president about I was attending a
Commonwealth summit meeting in Singapore
with the aid of Rwandan rebels he staged
a bloody coup proclaiming himself both
Prime Minister and president although
they heard about this on the flight home
from Singapore and diverted its flight
to Tanzania over the last couple of
years about his relationship with the
Western powers had been increasingly
turbulent as a result the change of
government was actually welcomed by
Western governments indeed about it was
also so unpopular at home that the
majority of Ugandan 's celebrated is
overthrowing the Western powers they had
high hopes for this new Ugandan regime
they felt that our men would be able to
check Russian influence in the region
what they knew a very our men they liked
he was a sportsman a national champion
boxer and a man who had failed the Army
Intelligence exam yet gone on to receive
a university doctorate what they didn't
realize was that Amin was a dictator of
unprecedented ruthlessness
[Music]
Emmons rule began with the number of
concessions political prisoners were
released the secret police was disbanded
and he promised the people that free and
open elections would be held but it
didn't take long for his true nature to
show itself he extended his period of
caretaking governance from 18 months to
5 years his reasoning was that he needed
time in order to reform the government
in a way that would truly benefit the
nation and then began to award himself
an increasingly bizarre succession of
titles including Lord of all beasts of
the earth and fishes of the sea in
August 1972 he set his sights on
reforming the economy in doing so he
identified a scapegoat for the country's
financial woes and that was the Asians
his solution was drastic all Asians even
those holding British passports were
expelled from Uganda he later revealed
that he had been given the message to
expel the Asians in vision from God
himself the 70,000 affected people were
given 90 days to leave the country or
face arrest imprisonment or worse what's
more is they could only take what
possessions and money they could carry
with them all property left behind would
be shared among immense cronies having
rid the country of the Asian problem I'm
in set out ridding the country of anyone
who was associated with the former
regime assassinations became routine and
extended to those even just associated
with the old British regime then British
businesses and property began to be
confiscated by the government British
and Jewish residents were expelled Great
Britain and Israel responded by cutting
off all diplomatic relations with Uganda
those countries also stopped supplying
garments to the region
I'm in now had to find a new supply of
arms he found it in Libya in order to
achieve that agreement Armand promised
that country's own dictator Muammar
Gaddafi that he would convert the nation
to Islam
the Ugandans dictator also turned to
Russia for military support giving them
the assurance that he would serve as a
stalwart of resistance against the
Western powers he also gave his support
to the Palestinian struggle against
Israel
back home I mean made sweeping changes
within the structure of the army 36
leading officers were told to report to
McKinley prison for special training in
subversion techniques but when they got
there they found themselves being thrown
into prison cells all 36 with in
bayonetta to death former army chief of
staff brigadier silliman hussein was
arrested and taken to another place of
confinement that the men who were
formerly under his command beat him to
death with their rifle butts that wasn't
all that happened to him his head was
cut off and sent our men at his new
house in Kampala it he had the Grizzly
trophy placed in the freezer compartment
of his refrigerator top army officers of
the two main barracks in the country
were told that they were to line up on
the parade grounds in order to salute an
incoming motorcade of tanks on both
occasions as the tanks came close they
ran off course and knocked down the
startled officers those that weren't
crushed to death were shot by waiting
riflemen at yet another barracks the
office corps were assembled in a room
and told that their president was on
route to deliver election bus as summons
entourage entered the barracks grenades
were thrown into the room and all of the
officers were killed within a few months
nearly every trained Army officer in
Uganda had been eliminated they were
replaced by members of Herman's Kokua
tribe men who had been tending goats in
the fields became high-ranking generals
overnight I'm in was largely able to
keep the slaughter that was occurring in
the army from the people as well as the
international community but when the
murderous rampage was extended to the
people in general the mask of civility
it was ripped off in the name of
protecting the order of his regime more
than half a million yoga nuns were
killed no one was immune with the murder
at all taking in chief justice's doctors
lawyers diplomats teachers and
journalists foreigners were also
murdered now just before we get into
even more
madness and I promise it gets worse like
feeding heads to crocodiles worse and
while you probably don't have to worry
about that you do have to deal with the
risks your online identity well Simon I
hear you cry we suddenly in an ad what
happens
yeah well decompression sickness aside
ads are important because they do help
us pay for these super long videos but
stick with me like I said this
crocodiles being fed human heads coming
up and who wouldn't want to stick around
for that
am i right also dashlane it's very cool
and basically it's free so there's also
that
dashlane is a one-stop digital identity
protection tool that includes a VPN for
all of your devices so you can use
public internet safely and anonymously
they also do something called dark web
monitoring which basically means that
they monitor the nasty underbelly of the
internet for people selling your data
and they will alert you if that is
happening further if a service you've
signed up for like Equifax or Sony maybe
suffers a breach - Lane will tell you
about it right away and they'll also
alert you to other services that share
that username and password so you can
change those before hackers get access
to your data on other sites plus - Lane
does what it's always done it stores
your passwords it keeps your personal
data secure and it fills all of those
annoying boxes for payment info and
passwords for you
a lot of - Lane is totally free but
there are some premium upgrades you can
buy if you want more from the service to
see if those are right for you you can
also get a free 30-day trial of them and
after that you can get a 10% discount
using our code biographic s' at - Lane
comm /by our graphics and let's get into
those crocodiles of being fed human
heads shall we
[Music]
unlike many other brutal dictators I'm
in took a personal hand in the slaughter
in fact he rather seemed to revel in it
he would personally torture people and
then feed their heads to crocodiles he
also proudly spoke about eating the
flesh of his enemies and as we've
already seen he had a thing for
preserving their heads in his fridge on
one infamous occasion in 1962 I'm in was
hosting a state dinner at his palace and
halfway through the meal he left the
table only to return with the frozen
head of brigadier Suleiman Hussein in
his hands his aghast guests to know
where to lurk as he proceeded to direct
a barrage of abuse up ahead and then
throw cutlery assets the new and
expanded army it needed funds and Amon
got them by diverting much-needed tax
income away from things like education
infrastructure and health and put it
into the Armed Forces Army courts were
given greater prominence than civil
courts Parliament it was dissolved in
all ministers were threatened with
arrest the more I'm in ratcheted up the
terror the more paranoid he appeared to
become he surrounded himself with the
security detail which numbered as many
as eighteen thousand these men doubled
as a ruthless death squad murdering
raping and pillaging at will on average
between 40 and 50 bodies were thrown
into Lake Victoria every single day in
1972 al stood president Beaute based in
Tanzania began making plans to retake
power gathering his force he made some
incursions across the border I'm in
retaliated by bombing Tanzanian towns
just across the border this effectively
put an end to about his ambitions for
power while the murderous chaos was
taking place within his borders Amin was
not shy about acting on the
international stage
he offered to broker peace in northern
ireland's encouraged the scottish to
break away from the commonwealth and
told african countries that they should
unite to oppose south africa he became
the chair of the organization of African
Unity Oh a you advocating that the
continent completely sever relations
with the West even went as far as to
declare that he not Queen Elizabeth was
the head of the Commonwealth in
accordance with this belief he then
awarded himself the Victoria Cross
[Music]
in establishing links with Russia and
Libya armen offered his support to the
Palestinian Liberation Organization or
PLO when members of the PLO hijacked a
plane enroute from Tel Aviv to Paris in
June of 1976 a men invited them to land
the plane at Entebbe Airport with 256
hostages to bargain with the to PLO
hijackers demanded the release of 53 PLO
prisoners held by the Israelis early on
one of the hostages and elderly person
by the name of Dora Bloch choked on some
food and was transported to Kampala
hospital I'm in threw himself into the
drama he quickly got himself to the
airport and in front of the hostages
images of him berating the passengers
were shown all around the world
156 passengers all of those who did not
hold Israeli passports were soon
released leaving 100 hostages ironically
the antalya airport had actually been
designed by israeli engineers back in
tel-aviv they were able to pull out the
plans for the airport and identify
exactly where the hostages were being
held the Israelis then devised a plan to
rescue the hostages in the early morning
hours of July the 3rd a team of Israeli
paratroopers raided the airport in the
ensuing firefight three of the hostages
were killed with another 10 being
injured seven of the hijackers along
with some 45 year and and soldiers who
fought in support of the hijackers were
also killed as was one of the rescuers
overall though the rescue it was a
stunning success
I mean was furious with the turn of
events with no one else to vent anger on
he ordered a couple of his thugs to the
compiled a hospital they burst into the
room that Dora Bloch was in and they
dragged the old woman away she was never
seen again if the world didn't realize
that the Ugandan dictator was stark
raving mad his stated intention to build
a memorial to Adolphe Hitler left them
with no doubt following the raid on
Entebbe on ins grip on power
oh he's beginning to weaken by now the
economy was a disaster an attempted coup
was staged in 1977 though unsuccessful
it ratcheted up immense power levels to
an all-time high
all of those suspected in being involved
in the plot were executed with entire
army units just being wiped out then in
an attempt to galvanize the people he
spread the lie that the Tanzania
were about to invade he mounted a series
of pre-emptive strikes against the
supposed invasion however he refused to
bride air support for the ground attacks
this led to the needless deaths of
thousands of his troops the Tanzanians
pushed the invaders back and then surged
into northern Uganda I'm in ad intended
for the war with Tanzania to be a
distraction from the problems at home
but the plan had backfired as the troops
surged into the country
locals join them in a spontaneous effort
to reclaim their country with the
ever-growing Tanzanian and local forces
closing in on Kampala I'm in made an
urgent broadcast urging the army to make
a stand at jigna but by now the army too
had abandoned him and the call it was
simply ignored seeing the writing on the
wall I'm in along with his five wives
and 35 children fled to Libya where they
were given sanctuary by Muammar Qaddafi
I'm in left his country with an
inflation rate in excess of 200% a
national debt of 340 million dollars and
the corpses of between 300 and 500
thousand of his own people as the people
struggle to recover under the reinstated
presidency of Milton of Beaute Harmon
and his family lived in relative luxury
under Gaddafi's largesse however the two
despots had a falling-out in 1981 and
I'm in left Libya for Saudi Arabia life
with the Saudis was a big come down for
a min and his family they now existed on
handouts provided by the Saudi
government he attempted to come back to
Uganda in 1988 with a small group of
armed followers but nothing came of it
the ends for the mad dictator came on
August the 16th 2003 he had fallen into
a coma the month before with his kidneys
failing and no signs of recovery his
family decided to turn off his
life-support he died with a quiet
dignity that he denied so many of his
victims
on hearing about the death of his former
army chief Milton about a called um in
the greatest brute that an African
mother has brought to life so sure I've
you found that video interesting if you
did please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this every day of the
week also thanks to dashlane please do
check them out below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]